encouraged president XI to advocate for
this exact essential key point which
must include the withdrawal of Russian
forces from Sovereign Ukrainian
territory consistent with the U.N
Charter the entire world would like to
see this war end especially the
ukrainians themselves who have put
forward their own plan for a just peace
which draws again on the same U.N
principles
we hope the president XI will press
President Putin to cease-bombing
Ukrainian cities hospitals and schools
to Halt the war crimes and atrocities
and to withdraw all his troops but we
are concerned that instead China will
reiterate calls for a ceasefire that
leaves Russian forces inside Ukraine's
Sovereign territory
any ceasefire that does not address the
removal of Russian forces from Ukraine
would effectively ratify Russia's
illegal conquests
efforts to end this conflict must take
Ukraine's position into account and so
we encourage president XI to play a
constructive role by speaking with
President zielinski which he has not
done since Russia launched this Invasion
because China quite frankly we believe
should hear directly from the ukrainians
and not just from the Russians and we
encourage president XI to press
President Putin directly on the need to
respect Ukraine's sovereignty and
territorial Integrity the world and
China's neighbors will certainly be
watching closely
uh you've heard the president say this
himself he wants to have another
conversation with President XI and he'll
do that and we'll do that at the most
appropriate time I don't have a call in
the schedule to speak to but it's
important that we keep those lines of
communication open particularly now when
tensions are so high that's why uh we're
you know we still want to get secretary
blinken uh back to Beijing that visit
was postponed it wasn't canceled uh and
we're still hopeful that we can get that
back on the counter as a matter of fact
we're having discussions with the PRC
right now about potential visit by uh
secretary Yellen and secretary raimondo
to go over there and talk about economic
issues so there's that that that that
we're still working so all of that
keeping those lines of communication
open uh are still valuable we don't know
if uh there's going to be some sort of
arrangement I would just tell you that
we still don't believe that China's
taking it off the table
we still don't believe and haven't seen
any indication that they're moving in
that direction or they've made a
decision to provide or that they're
actually going to do that
we continue to believe it's not in
China's best interest to do that to help
Mr Putin Slaughter innocent ukrainians
it's hard to believe that they would
think that that's in their best interest
it would also run counter uh to what
we've heard president XI talk about in
terms of what his ultimate goal here is
I think he put an op-ed out today
talking about sovereignty territory
Integrity finding a peaceful way to end
this war that uh providing lethal
weapons would seem to be inconsistent uh
with that goal
uh so I hope he got to see what his
troops his military and his war did to
that city
um uh but we'll but we'll let him speak
to uh to to to his uh to what he came
away from uh I would also tell you that
it's clear
um
that he knows he has to know how badly
he's doing inside Ukraine uh I mean more
than 50 percent of the territory they
took from Ukraine in the first weeks and
months of the war the ukrainians have
already taken back and the only real
active fighting right now is around back
Moot and here we are on what is it today
the 20th and back mood is still not in
Russian hands now they're fighting over
it but the ukrainians aren't giving up
on it